-Welcome back, Jason.
How are you, buddy?
-Not too bad, you know.
Healthy, and -- but locked up
and going crazy, like everyone.
-I think we were going so crazy
and so locked up with our kids
that we took the step of
actually using them
in a sketch.
We did
a "Second Chance Theater,"
which now seems like
a long time ago.
-I know.
-And I could only use,
in the end, one of my kids.
Axel, it turned out,
was too young to act.
So Ashe was in it,
but both Daisy and Otis
came through big time.
Are they different actors?
Are they different
kinds of performers?
-Very different.
Very different process.
Yeah, Otis is, like,
a premise guy.
He's like one of those kids
that I had friends
growing up like that.
They're like, "Hey, what
if Mr. Doyle did this?"
You know, and you just sort of
sit in the back of
the classroom, and you're kind
of pretending,
"What if we threw something
into the fan?"
And Otis is that guy.
And then Daisy is just full-on
Daniel Day-Lewis.
She's just in it the whole time.
She wakes up Olivia
almost every morning,
coming into our room going,
"Mama, will you pretend
I'm a baby horse named,"
you know, "Screwdriver?"
And then, Liv is, "Okay, yeah.
Come here, sweetie."
And then she crawls into bed.
And then, she just, "Mm, mm"
and then, does the same thing.
But she will stay in it forever
until you yell "cut,"
and then sometimes beyond.
-She definitely -- She was
the standout of the three.
I will willingly admit that.
-Yeah.
-Your wife Olivia also had
the idea -- this was --
Ted Lasso was a character you
did in a series of commercials
for NBC Sports
a few years back now.
And Olivia was the one who
suggested that maybe this could
expand into, you know,
the kind of character
that could carry a show.
-Yeah.
And I totally forgot about that
until Brendan mentioned it,
our buddy, Brendan Hunt,
who is on the show
and was one of
the producers/writers.
He mentioned it in the press,
and then Liv mentioned it to me
at home.
I was like, "Really?"
She was like, "Yeah."
We were out to dinner.
And she explained
the whole thing to me,
and she just liked the fact
that we enjoyed doing it,
loved working with, you know,
our buddies Brendan and Joe.
And similar to the reason I
enjoy doing it because it's --
he's just in a good mood
a lot of times.
Especially by the time we did
the second commercial,
and she was like,
"You should look at doing this
as a TV show or a movie."
And then she reminded me
of that.
I just sort of sat there at
dinner and just started riffing.
I was like, "Why is he so happy?
Oh, maybe he's going
through something."
And then I kind of just went in
my head and ruminated over,
you know, deviled eggs
or who knows what, some --
back when you could go
to restaurants.
Anything's possible.
-And this was --
you know, I really --
I love the commercials, and they
definitely played off the idea
of a fish out of water,
an American football coach
who is in charge of
a British soccer team.
I will say I was surprised
and delighted by the change
in sort of tone of this show.
I mean, there's still
the fish-out-of-water quality,
but you have
a very upbeat, optimistic,
sort of Jimmy Stewart-type
attitude about
what you're embarking on
as this coach.
-High praise, yeah.
I really do believe that that
happened from getting to do
with the second commercial
because the first commercial,
the whole premise was
that he gets hired by
the Tottenham Hotspurs and then
gets fired three days later.
And so when those commercials
did well, they asked us to do
a second one, but they're like,
"But you can't go to the U.K.
We don't have the budget
for that."
It was like, "Okay. Alright."
Well, then, maybe he just
loved his brief time there
and fell in love with the sport.
And it was that, like,
childlike enthusiasm
that really unlocked it for me
and made it really fun to play.
And I just think him being
relentlessly stupid
would be impossible.
Our big rule in
the writers' room was like,
"He's seen 'SportsCenter.'
You know, like, "He knows
the ball has to go in the net."
-I do like that he is a --
It shows that you can be cheery
and optimistic and also
not stupid
because even when people make
fun of him, he is both cheery,
and you can tell on your face
as an actor, is aware
that he has just been burned.
-Yes.
-I like that depth of character.
-Thanks.
-It really, like, steers away
from being cartoonish at all,
which I think is just fantastic.
-Yeah, the mustache is
about as cartoony as it gets.
We really -- But, yeah, that was
a big thing for us, was --
I also love that -- do you
remember that Del Close quote,
you know, our improv guru?
Did you have him
when you were in Chicago? Yeah.
-I missed him. I missed him.
-Yeah.
Yeah, you were in --
you were at Boom.
You were in Amsterdam
at that time
when he was doing his thing.
-Yeah.
-But he would say, "Treat your
audience like poets and geniuses
and they'll rise to
the occasion."
And I feel like, you know,
Ted -- it's nice to know that
it is coming across that,
yeah, Ted knows
he's being insulted.
He just -- He just knows that
it's -- Well, they don't know me
well enough to really be
talking about me.
You know, the other thing
we talk about is, like,
Ted is kind of like mushrooms.
He's sort of egoless,
and people put
their own thing on him,
and he's just kind of like,
"Yeah, alright. Well, okay."
It just bounces off him
because, again,
if you don't know someone,
how can you hate them already?
It's not for the right reasons.
It's their own stuff,
and it doesn't rattle him in
the least because, you know,
he's kind of like, "Oh, you
know, I'll find my way here."